yes we are emergency we are
depressurized we do need to return back
too we have 177 passengers is 188 the
distress call from the pilot of Alaska
Airlines flight 1282 to air traffic
control a gaping hole in the side of the
aircraft full fuel tanks and terrified
passengers at risk of being sucked out
of the cabin at 16,000 ft or nearly
5,000 met up we just heard like a loud
thing I look to my left there's just
this huge like gaping hole first I
thought it was the emergency door but
there was no door there it was just like
a part of the wall that flew off it
could have been much much worse but the
two seats next to the hole were empty we
are the global gold standard for safety
around the world but we have to maintain
that standard we are very very fortunate
here that this didn't end up
in something more uh tragic it was the
external door plug which blew off a
door- shaped section of fuselage where a
working door could be fitted but in this
case the plug should have been bolted
securely shut given but it is pluged of
course it is expected to be a a secure
part of the structure of the aircraft
and that's why it's all the more
surprising and a matter of concern that
this uh this blowout happened in
response Alaska Airline said it was
temporarily grounding its Fleet of 65
max9 aircraft as a precaution pending
the outcome of safety checks the US Air
safety regulator further ordered a total
of 171 Jets of the same model to be
grounded until they too can be checked
Paul Brennan Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer